life is busy enough without all the
added push notifications
oh come on Instagram I'm late for work
almost every app is grasping to pull us
out of the real world and into the
digital one
breaking news Facebook breaking news
they bug us everywhere and I mean
everywhere and they bug us about
everything oh come on
and anything seriously anything oh this
is important and that right there is the
biggest problem with push notifications
it's very hard to find the important
ones in a sea of unimportant ones but we
can't let them win and the answer isn't
just turning them all off set aside 15
minutes and do the following number one
shut off the worst offenders there are
two places to control the notifications
within the apps themselves you can
attempt to control what you're notified
about within the iOS and Android
notification settings menu you can turn
off notifications entirely for apps in
there go through the list of apps and
silence the apps you never want to hear
from number to preserve the lock screen
in the iOS and Android settings you then
decide what's worth interrupting you on
your lock screen deep thought a
notification that doesn't hit the lock
screen isn't a notification at all my
lock screen for example is now only home
to emails and chat messages thanks
number three outsmart the social apps
I suggest turning off social media
alerts altogether but if you don't make
sure to master their complicated in-app
settings and Facebook go to settings
account settings notifications and then
mobile Instagram has a similar menu in
its app I encourage you to turn off as
much as you can don't be fooled by the
personalized nature of these settings
Facebook pro tip tap the upper right
corner of a post and select turn off
notification so you don't get notified
every time someone else comments on the
post number four do not disturb both
Android and iOS have Do Not Disturb
modes which silence all notifications
when you turn it on its there so don't
be afraid to use it
that should leave you with the real
peace and quiet at least until you turn
it back on again this is like Deadpool
but better